[Música]
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden ofreció una cena de estado para su
homólogo francés emanio almacén la Casa
Blanca previamente los líderes
sostuvieron un encuentro en el que
vaiden se comprometió a ajustar la ley
de reducción de la inflación para no
perjudicar a empresas del sector verde
en Europa
El Congreso de Perú aprobó discutir la
moción de vacancia contra el presidente
Pedro Castillo presentada por la
oposición que argumenta que el
mandatario está en permanente
incapacidad moral para estar al frente
del gobierno ampliamos la información
desde Lima
la Corte Internacional de Justicia de la
haya puso fin a la disputa entre chile y
Bolivia sobre el estatuto de las aguas
del río silala lo que termina el
conflicto legal entre ambos países en
2016 chile demandó a Bolivia tras las
declaraciones del entonces presidente
Evo Morales que acusaba a Chile de robar
y desviar las aguas del silala
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano y del mundial de fútbol soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en Estados Unidos
porque el presidente joeyden ofreció una
cena de estado asomólogo francés Emanuel
makou este jueves esto luego del
encuentro que los líderes mantuvieron en
la tarde en el que biden se comprometió
a realizar cambios a la ley de reducción
de la inflación que preocupa a Europa el
viernes viajará a Nueva Orleans donde
anunciará planes para ampliar el apoyo a
la enseñanza de la lengua francesa en
las escuelas de Estados Unidos Samuel
Salgado nos amplía detalles de la
jornada del jueves
Emanuel macón llegó a la casa blanca
para limar asperezas con Joe biden la
discusión bilateral se centró en la ley
de reducción de inflación estadounidense
que la Casa Blanca promovió para
fortalecer la economía y que fue tildada
de proteccionista por macón sin embargo
ahora los líderes coinciden en un
trabajo más coordinado como lo mostró
nuestra discusión el objetivo de los
Estados Unidos no es limitar el acceso a
sus industrias y hay proyectos ahora en
curso pero yo sé que esta no es la
intención del presidente biden pude
hablarlo ayer con distintos senadores y
representantes en el congreso
biden reforzó que la agenda de los
países aliados debe ser común y
beneficiosa para todos en temas
comerciales tecnológicos y de cambio
climático
mi punto es que estamos de vuelta los
negocios Europa también y vamos a
continuar creando trabajadores en
manufactura en Estados Unidos pero no a
expensas de Europa
otro tema protagonista de la conferencia
de prensa fue la guerra en Ucrania el
presidente ha propuesto un plan de paz
en diez puntos y creo que tenemos que
trabajar con él Porque existe una
voluntad real de parte de los ucranianos
de entrar al campo de las discusiones lo
reconocemos y lo felicitamos
bailen por su parte aseguró que no tiene
planes inmediatos de reunirse con Putin
pero
estoy preparada para hablar con el
presidente Putin
Sí realmente hay un interés de su parte
y si está buscando una manera de
terminar la guerra y él no ha hecho esto
aún el mensaje es claro Washington y
París seguirán actuando en conjunto en
defensa de Ucrania siguiendo la línea de
la otan organización en la que Estados
Unidos es el principal contribuyente y
Francia el tercero se espera que este
viernes Emmanuel macón concluya su
visita a Estados Unidos en Luisiana
vamos a Perú porque el congreso aceptó
discutir la más reciente moción de
vacancia que presentó la oposición para
destituir al presidente Pedro Castillo
los demandantes aseguran que el
mandatario lidera Un gobierno corrupto
con aspiraciones totalitarias a la vez
el tribunal constitucional emitió una
medida cautelar para evitar la
disolución del Congreso Francisco
Zacarías corresponsal de France 24 en
Lima nos amplió la información
con 73 votos a favor 32 en contra y seis
abstenciones al congreso de Perú admitió
a debate la tercera moción de vacancia
presidencial contra Pedro Castillo la
sesión ha sido programada para el
miércoles 7 de diciembre a las tres de
la tarde el parlamento ha enviado el
dictamen al mandatario peruano con fecha
y hora para que acuda al congreso con su
abogado a fin de que pueda ejercer su
derecho a la defensa hay que señalar que
la moción fue presentada con el respaldo
de 67 firmas de los legisladores y hoy
se aprobó la admisión a debate con 73
votos todavía es un misterio si la
derecha peruana que dirige el parlamento
en este país podrá conseguir los 87
votos necesarios para el impeachment por
otro lado también hoy el tribunal
constitucional de este país dictó una
medida cautelar a favor del Congreso
mientras se decide la demanda
competencial contra Pedro Castillo por
la cuestión de confianza y suspende
cualquier interpretación del ejecutivo
Así mismo dispone que el gobierno no
altere ni modifique la situación del
parlamento el tribunal le dice a Pedro
Castillo que si quisiera asumir una
primera confianza negada con la
finalidad de cerrar el parlamento no
podrá hacerlo
la Corte Internacional de Justicia de la
haya puso fin a la disputa entre chile y
Bolivia sobre el estatuto de las aguas
del río silala y pone así fin al
conflicto en materia legal entre ambos
países los jueces concluyeron que ya
fueron acordados puntos previdos sobre
el acceso a las aguas consideradas un
curso de agua internacional por lo que
no será necesaria una decisión sobre los
reclamos de chile la corte en esencia
dijo que no se pronunciaba ya que las
partes habían acordado el carácter
Internacional del silala presidente
Gabriel borich felicitó la decisión
mientras que su homólogo boliviano Luis
Arce dijo que el alto tribunal había
ratificado los derechos de su país sobre
esas aguas
sostuvimos desde un comienzo es que el
río silala era un curso de agua
internacional y que por lo tanto se
regía por el derecho internacional
constitudinario y que chile había hecho
y hace un uso equitativo y razonable de
las de estas aguas en virtud de el
derecho internacional No
exigimos nada más Y eso ha sido
concedido por la corte y por lo tanto
nosotros nos declaramos satisfechos con
esto Hablamos ahora del más reciente
informe de amnistía internacional en el
que presentó pruebas sobre 28 casos en
los que funcionarios de la policía de
Colombia agredieron sexualmente a
manifestantes en las protestas
anticobernamentales de 2021 según el
documento los hechos estuvieron bajo un
patrón generalizado que pretendía
castigar a los manifestantes veamos más
detalles en el informe de Juan Pablo
al menos 28 personas sufrieron
agresiones sexuales a manos de policías
durante el paro nacional de 2021 en
Colombia según el informe de amnistía
internacional se trató de un patrón
generalizado de violencia Estatal las
violaciones de Derechos Humanos tuvieron
lugar principalmente en dos situaciones
durante la actuación de la Policía
Nacional para dispersar las protestas y
durante las detenciones que siguieron a
la intervención inicial en ambas
situaciones actuando a título oficial
hubo agentes de la Policía Nacional que
cometieron actos que iban desde los
insultos sexistas y las amenazas hasta
la violencia sexual la organización
describió específicamente los 28 casos
de las cientos de denuncias recibidas el
informe de 68 páginas presenta el
contexto de violencia previo a las
protestas que vivía el país así como los
casos de impunidad y las limitaciones
para la atención y garantía de acceso a
la justicia
in relation no ha habido ni una sola
condena en relación con las múltiples
violaciones de Derechos Humanos
cometidos durante estas protestas y ni
una sola condena penal en relación con
la violencia sexual el gobierno debe
reconocer lo que sucedió públicamente
con firmeza debe disculparse por lo que
se hizo con los cuerpos de jóvenes con
la mujer y la juventud y con los
afrocolombianos
según amnistía internacional los abusos
de índole sexual tuvieron lugar entre el
28 de abril y el 30 de junio de 2021
cuando miles de colombianos salieron a
las calles para rechazar la gestión del
gobierno del entonces presidente Iván
Duque finalizamos en Qatar porque este
viernes se juega la jornada número 12
del mundial de fútbol los ojos de
América Latina se posan sobre Brasil ya
clasificado y Uruguay aún en la cuerda
floja se trata de la última jornada de
la fase de grupos desde doha Juan
pupiales enviado especial de France 24
nos amplió los detalles de la jornada
se cierra la fase de grupos de este
mundial de Qatar 2022 el grupo H y el
grupo G definen a sus últimos cuatro
clasificados para los octavos de final
comenzando con el grupo H hay una final
la de gana y Uruguay los africanos que
tienen el futuro en sus manos para
clasificar a octavos con una victoria
contra los charrúas el antecedente es el
de Sudáfrica 2010 cuando los uruguayos
se eliminaron a gana en cuartos de final
en una gonica de tanda de penaltis con
Uruguay habrá cambios en la alineación
titular del seleccionador Diego Alonso
se habla de la incorporación de
jugadores como Nicolás de la cruz o
Georgia de arrascaeta lo único claro es
que es defensa del Barcelona Ronald
Araujo no estará disponible para este
partido en el otro partido del grupo
Portugal ya clasificada se mide una
Corea del Sur que es la que más difícil
lo tiene en este grupo por el grupo G
Cameron se mide contra Brasil a Cameron
Solamente le vale ganar se mide una
Brasil que tendrá un equipo
completamente nuevo incluso desde la
portería de Comenzando por ederson
también Incluso se habla de que jugará
Dani Alves lateral derecho en el otro
partido del día Suiza y Serbia se miden
a suiza que le vale con una victoria a
los serbios que tendrían que ganar y
esperar con el antecedente Eso sí de ese
tenso partido de Rusia 2018 cuando
Shakira celebraron sus goles contra
Serbia haciendo el águila albana
haciendo una reconocimiento a sus
orígenes fin del informativo volvemos en
breve
[Música]